well we all own the most powerful
biocomputer in the world in the universe
and most people don't know how to change
their brain to change their income most
people don't know how do i let go of
limiting beliefs like i'm too young or
too old or i live in this part of the
world or that part of the world or i'm
black and white amazing whatever it is
whatever the limiting belief is is
nothing more than a
pattern in the brain so let me ask all
of you that are watching right now are
you interested
in achieving two or three times the
income in the next 12 months are you
interested okay in having a great
physique or are you committed are you
interested or committed to having the
life of your dreams that's extraordinary
instead of ordinary or below ordinary
because here's the truth
hey hey hey
and there he is mr john astroup in the
house hey buddy how are you good how are
you happy tuesday happy tuesday hi
everyone nice to see you all
are you
are you coming in live from toronto
yes sir i'm in toronto john's there in
his home in california
if you guys don't know john he's the
author of this amazing book
inner size he's got his copy behind i
got mine here he's also the amazing
founder of the brain-a-thons which we're
going to talk about today this is his
ninth annual brainathon coming up of all
the guys that i know and i profile a lot
of them
john is the most
in tune with the latest science on how
to hack your brain
to start getting results and i think
your brain can be your best friend or it
could be your
your worst enemy as well
uh and that's what the brain is all
about i'm gonna we're gonna have a quick
chat about it so so uh for youtube
there's a link to join underneath in the
description about john's latest
brain-a-thon john the uh
the theme that i saw on the website is
change your brain
change your income yeah which i love
tell us
why changing our brain changes our
income
so one of the questions that i always
ask my students and people is um why do
you earn
what you're earning whether it's per
hour per day per month per week per year
why do you earn that amount
and is it because of your knowledge your
skills or is it because of something
other than that as well
and a question that i always ask is
is it possible that
us humans we get conditioned
to earn and expect a certain amount of
income is it possible we get conditioned
to earn is it possible that our brain
sometimes acts like a thermostat and
once the thermostat is set at a certain
temperature
its responsibility is to keep the room
at that certain temperature well
is it possible that we have you know an
income
set point
is it possible that we have a wealth set
point is it possible
that maybe we have some beliefs that
hold us back or some habits that hold us
hostage is it possible that we will
never
outperform our hidden self-image
so if i want to earn let's say twice as
much money per hour per day per week per
you know per month
but my self image says but am i really
worth it
can i really achieve it am i good enough
am i smart enough
when we have these internal
dialogues and these internal conflicts
in many cases
then we might have one foot on the gas
and one foot on the brake and even
though we have so much potential
we keep repeating the patterns
that we have become accustomed to
repeating
and so why change your brain change your
income
well we all own the most powerful bio
computer in the world in the universe
and most people don't know how to change
their brain to change their income most
people don't know how do i let go of
limiting beliefs like i'm too young or
too old or i live in this part of the
world or that part of the world or you
know i'm i'm black and white i'm asian
whatever it is whatever the limiting
belief is is nothing more than a
pattern in the brain
a habit's nothing more than a pattern in
the brain a uh fear fear of failing fear
of being embarrassed ashamed ridiculed
judged rejected disappointed
those are all
part of our brain and how many people
have learned how to utilize their brain
better so it's a tool of mass
construction
instead of a tool of mass destruction
i love that john assaraf man i missed
you uh hi everyone i missed you too my
friend
so listen one of the ways that i've
tried to fight that is to always be
around people who are doing so much more
right that when i talk to you or just
watch your videos or from profiling elon
musk or oprah winfrey or any of these
people it's like just that extra little
energy and just a change of environment
pulls me forward in modern success not
just the strategies but just the energy
yeah
what do you what do you recommend
for people who are trying to break free
of those living beliefs
what what what are their steps obviously
brain-a-thon
but like as a bigger picture how do we
break free of those of that automatic
pattern
um everything starts with awareness
so if i ask somebody right now maybe
everybody can you want to play along
everyone
right if uh if if i asked everybody
who's watching right now and even in the
future say what is one limiting belief
that you have
that's preventing you let me repeat one
limiting belief you currently have right
now
that's preventing you from doubling your
income in the next 12 months one
limiting belief type it in the chat
right now one
limiting belief you have what's a
limiting belief it's a belief that
limits you
right i mean we just flip it around so
belief i have that's limiting you and so
here's a question that i ask you
um so we have real
uh real stan harvey i'm not good enough
to double my income in the next 12
months uh i am somebody says my age
write it out i am too old or i'm too
young right so write out what the
limiting belief is i'm not smart enough
to double my income
right um i can't start a business
because i can't provide enough value i
don't have a degree i don't have the
resources i don't have the ability i'm
not qualified enough i feel i'm too
lad and don't have enough education i
don't have the time i'm not good enough
money is hard work i could not do it
i don't know where to start so whenever
we have
a limiting belief a belief that limits
us
my question for you is this okay
everybody play play along with us
is that the truth
is that the real truth
or is that
something you've just gotten used to
saying and believing
now what if you just took your belief
that you have right now that's limiting
you what if you just did this just for a
moment as soon as i
repeat to myself
i can't because and i have a reason
it's a belief the reason is the belief
what do you think your brain does your
brain is a bio computer that reinforces
your beliefs right
we have a belief we just keep
reinforcing it and then we think and
feel and behave in ways that reinforce
our beliefs right because we don't want
to be wrong so our brain just says okay
if you believe that let me have you
think and feel and do the things that
resonate and match what you believe
what if you just use this simple simple
easy technique
watch this everyone what if you just
changed your self-talk in one language
pattern
in the past i used to believe and write
down what that negative or limiting
belief in the past i used to believe
that i didn't have the ability i didn't
have the skill i didn't have the
knowledge and have the money didn't have
the the education uh in the past i used
to believe this and now i'm learning
exactly how to double my income in the
next 12 months regardless of what i used
to believe
what do you think that does to your bio
computer well when we reinforce a
limiting belief
it reinforces our behavior to make it
true as soon as we change the language
past say in the past i used to and now
i'm learning
the skills the knowledge the time
management how to add value how to make
more money how to double my income
now we just opened up the brain
to say oh what i used to believe that
limited me happened in the past what i'm
now choosing to believe that'll help
make sure that my today next week the
week after moves me towards what i want
now i've just opened up my bio computer
because
i can
so we don't want to reinforce limiting
beliefs we want to
change them we want to change our brain
so we can change our paradigm how we see
the world in ourselves we want to change
our brains we can change our beliefs we
want to change our brain so we can
create new habits we want to change our
brain so that our habits match
the goals that we want to achieve now
let me ask you all a question watch what
i'm going to do right now can i keep
going on yeah yeah it is it's great
let's go all right everybody i want you
to i want to prove something to you
right now if you want to play full out
right now get the love button just hit
the love button right now hit it a
couple of times
get me and heaven excited if you want to
play right now i'm going to show you one
thing that'll prove what i just said all
right ready
i want you to imagine
somebody that you love i mean you really
love this person in your life it could
be
a wife a husband a child a brother a
sister a best friend and even if you
want a pet like a dog or a cat that you
love okay can you imagine this person or
this pet now i want you to imagine this
i want you to imagine that today
all right it's 11 11
a.m
on tuesday morning in san diego right i
want you to imagine that today you make
a commitment
that one year from today you're going to
learn
the beliefs that you need the habits you
need the knowledge and the skills you
need to double your income and you're
going to make a goal today that one year
from today you're going to double your
income and you commit to it which means
no stories no excuses no reasons and
nothing's going to stand in your new
commit 12 months from now
and what if i said this
the person or the animal that you just
thought of that you love
if you don't do everything it takes
honestly with integrity to double your
income 12 months from now you will never
see that person again
you will not see that animal you'll
never see them again 12 months a day how
many of you will let go of your limiting
beliefs
will you let go of your fear of being
embarrassed ashamed or ridiculed judged
would you let go of your fear of failure
would you let go of fear of
disappointing yourself would you let go
of any story reason or excuse you now
have and would you do whatever it took
legally ethically professionally above
the line to double your income how many
of you would do whatever it takes and
you would upgrade your identity to match
that new destiny
would you upgrade your identity to match
the destiny so you become the person
capable of doing this
now listen if you said yes which i
imagine if you're breathing and you're
smart which you are you probably said
yes you do whatever it takes well
what if i shared with you we know how to
let go of limiting beliefs we know how
to help you have more focus more
concentration we know how to upgrade
your knowledge and skills today more
than at any other time in the history of
our species right we know how to take
small little baby steps so we're making
progress on the way to what we want we
know how to upgrade identity and
self-image and self-worth we know how to
help you manage your fear of failure
those are emotions that we feel so it's
a matter of upgrading yourself changing
your brain so you change your income and
just so we're clear it's not about the
money
the only purpose of the income is to
give you more choice freedom to give you
more peace of mind to give you more
abilities to enjoy life better for
yourself your family and your loved ones
and to make a difference in the lives of
others
right money is just a tool so is it
possible
based on today's neuroscience and
neuropsychology
research to learn how to let go of
what's holding you back
and start to become the person who can
double her income or his income in the
next 12 months
because if you don't then guess what
you're saying by
by default
i am okay being stuck and not only that
but i'm going to reinforce the very
beliefs that are holding me back
because i'm going to let another year go
by
so there's a little bit of fun and and
uh and evan i don't know if um um
we set up a um
a link if you want me to give it on how
people can sign up
yeah you can you can see it here on ig
we're going to link it below uh for the
youtube video guys just go check out
john's brain-a-thon 9th annual type in
john astro brain-a-thon you will find it
just
yeah just dm me in on instagram dm me
brain
and you'll get an automatic link to sign
up it's free it's october 23rd and uh
it'll blow your mind with me and
a few other brain experts so keep going
what i love about you is
one just a heart
to share right i mean
there's no need for you to keep doing
this and yet
it's like you're only picking up energy
there it is look at that dude
you don't need to do this and guys you
know i've known a lot of people in the
personal development industry just by
the nature of what i do and john is
definitely one of the good guys and just
keeps showing up every single day which
i love um
one of the the other thing i love about
you you're great at taking
the subconscious and making it conscious
and
when you ask what what are your limiting
beliefs you just saw a whole bunch of
garbage that people were dumping out all
of these things like imagine this is
what's happening every day in your mind
without even noticing it and what you
did was give us two fantastic exercises
in you know saying in the past i used to
believe this and then imagine in your
loved ones
you know you're never going to see them
again as you fix it these are now moving
the subconscious to conscious
what do you recommend
to keep that momentum going because you
know here people are thinking yeah oh my
gosh i need to do this this is crazy but
then they wake up tomorrow and they're
still they can fall back into the
patterns is this put it into our
calendar like how do we keep that energy
going sure so listen we're you know if
everybody um
answers this question we are all
creatures of
how right everybody knows that we're all
creatures of habit well what is a habit
why do we why does our brain develop you
know these habitual patterns you know we
can have habitual thought patterns we
can have habitual emotional patterns we
can have habitual behavioral patterns
those three things uh obviously create
what we do and don't do right
so were you born with any habits like
were you born with any habits and the
answer is no
so that means that i developed habits
and the habits the behaviors the thought
emotional and behavioral patterns that
were reinforced
became automatic
right so what do we know about habits
hold on
would you all agree that all your habits
are in your brain not your plastic brain
but in your brain
well we also know that there's a place
in the brain um and we've only been able
to look deep in the brain you know um
with uh spect scans and um and uh mris
we've only been able to look deeper into
the human range like in the last 10
years and so we now know
that there's there's a certain um part
of the brain
called the striatum that's connected to
the hippocampus the memory part of our
brain and this part of our brain works
together with our motivational circuit
in our behavioral circuit
and uh nina i'll correct you in just a
moment it does not take 21 days but i'll
tell you how long it does take and so
what happens is this part of our brain
okay makes automatic anything that we've
repeated over a month two months three
months six months 12 months so we might
have automatic negative thoughts that
become normalized then that's a habit we
might have automatic negative emotions i
call the automatic negative thoughts
ants which is from dr daniel eamon a
good good friend of mine and evans uh he
you know how do we stomp the ants and
how do we stop the automatic negative
emotions here's what we know based on
the latest research from the university
of london
it takes between pay close attention
everyone because it's going to change
your mindset about what it's going to
take it takes between 66 days
and
365 days to change a habitual pattern
that we've had for five years 10 years
20 years 30 years so let me ask you a
question
if i tell you
if you want to change a thought pattern
that's negative or destructive or
disempowering you if you want to change
a disempowering negative emotional
pattern if you want to change a
disempowering destructive negative
behavior or habitual pattern and i'm
telling you
it's going to take you between 66 days
and 365 days like wouldn't you put a
plan together to at least change it for
66 days
like all of my students
must agree to at least 100 days of
retraining their brain changing their
rates and they change their income their
weight their relationship their career
their business so 100 days minimum now
let me ask you a question
if you were out of shape
out of shape you're overweight out of
breath you're out of shape and i said
you hey
do you want to
get into better shape
and j monique it takes between 66 and
365 days depending on how deeply rooted
the habit is so it doesn't take 67 days
between 66 and 365 so
if you knew that you could get into
shape by exercising a little bit each
day
whether it's walking whether it's being
on the bike doing pilates doing yoga
whether it's weight training whether
it's hiking whatever it is
you could accelerate getting into shape
okay by doing it maybe twice a day if
you want to so we could exercise to get
into better shape the reason i wrote the
book inner size
right the new science to unlock your
brain's hidden power the reason we do
the brain-a-thon
is to show you all of the basic
techniques to strengthen your mindset to
develop the beliefs the habits right the
activities that are required to achieve
your goals hey there ray higdon ray's
the world class champ too i don't know
if you know him evan but you guys should
be playing together okay
um right so so is there a way to double
down on retraining your brain so i'll
give you an example
let's say
you decide that you want to uh change
your self image because you have a low
self image you have a neural path says
i'm not worthy right i don't deserve the
success that i have well i could say
okay
starting today i'm going to start doing
things that's going to make me feel more
worthy more deserving i'm going to
upgrade my knowledge i'm going to
upgrade my skills i'm going to take some
inspired action but what if
i also closed my eyes
and i started visualizing feeling worthy
i started to emotionalize i am worthy
i'm a spiritual being with all the
potential within me and i deserve to
achieve all my goals and dreams what if
i did that one time
10 times 100 times is it true
that visualization is simulation
in the brain
so whatever i simulate
is that not also activating cells in my
brain
are those cells not creating connections
and is that not the same as if i do you
know a bicep curl one time five times
ten times i'm building my muscle well if
i visualize and i emotionalize am i not
building my neuro muscle around my
self-image self-worth self-esteem and
self-confidence so i could behave in
ways i can visualize i can emotionalize
i can activate the neurons in my brain
to formulate
a brand new pattern that if i uh repeat
that pattern
i'm not creating a stronger neural
pattern than my old self-image or
self-worth so i could behave my way into
a
you know greater self-image or
self-worth but i can also visualize and
emotionalize i can also use language
patterns so there are a variety of
different ways to speed up the process
so
if you're gonna do it
why not at least commit to 100 days
why 100 days well because we know it
takes between 66 and 365. how long will
it take you to get in shape if you're
out of shape and overweight and you eat
like [ __ ] and you don't have energy well
depends on how out of shape you are how
you know how your how poor your habits
are
so
how long should it take it depends on
you not on me all the techniques are
there
but there's one thing that's going to
determine whether you actually do this
or not
ready to answer that one
let's go
many years ago
my first mentor
asked me what are my goals and my dreams
and i'm going to make this story short
and i said well i want to you know
retire at 45 i want to have 3 million
dollars i want to retire my parents and
have them living
comfortably i want to travel the world i
want a nice car i want a beautiful home
i want nice italian clothes etc i want i
want i want i want
and he said to me says everything that
you want you can have
every one of these things i was 19 at
the time and he looked at me and he said
i'm going to ask you one question the
answer to this question will determine
whether you have the money the house uh
you know the the success that you want
how many of you want to know what the
question was that changed my life if you
want to know the question that changed
my life either type in john tell me the
one question please tell me the one
question
all right
i love g do you want me to know the
question yes or no i need to see the
feedback loop because that's what
releases the dopamine in my brain the
feel good chemical
right all right so here's what he asked
me
are you interested
in achieving these things
or are you committed
am i interested am i committed he said
are you interested or are you committed
and when i asked him
what's the difference
you know what he said to me
he said if you're interested you'll
allow your limiting beliefs to hold you
back if you're interested you'll allow
your circumstances and your present
conditions to hold you back if you're
interested you'll keep doing the same
thing over and over and over again and
you'll come up with stories reasons and
excuses why you can't do it he says but
when you are committed
you will upgrade pay attention now
you will upgrade your identity to match
the destiny and the goals that you have
you will upgrade your knowledge your
skills your beliefs your habits and your
daily weekly monthly behaviors so that
you become the type of person
capable of achieving every one of those
goals so let me ask all of you that are
watching right now are you interested in
achieving two or three times the income
in the next 12 months are you interested
okay in having a great physique or are
you committed are you interested or
committed to having the life of your
dreams that's extraordinary instead of
ordinary or below ordinary because
here's the truth
you will never do whatever it takes
until you are committed and you will
become somebody that masters
disappointment instead of mastering the
discipline required for change
boom that's it interested or committed
that is the defining question for all of
us that want to achieve more in our
lives
i love it i love i just put down in the
chat dm john the word brain if you want
to get on ig and for youtube we'll link
up down below the brain-a-thon john what
happens out of brain-a-thon this is this
is nine years of you doing this you are
the expert obviously you're there guys
we love the energy and wisdom and like
you just see how john shows up
just wait for the brain-a-thon but then
you also bring in
some other leading experts so what
happens inside the brain-a-thon sure so
um because every day i get to research
and find out the best in neuroscience
and neuropsychology of you know how do i
develop more self-confidence how do i
stay more focused how do i let go of
habits that don't serve me and create
habits that do um how do i um increase
my awareness how do i take inspired
action all the time
i play with some of the top
neuroscientists and neuropsychologists
and success experts in the world so
every year i do this brain-a-thon where
we bring some of the best experts for a
full day of training it's free
we could charge a thousand dollars for
it and we don't we just bring the expert
so this year
i'll be one of the experts like every
year uh we have uh jack canfield who
rode chicken soup for the soul sold 500
million books
lisa nichols will be on there as well
who's a rock star of success dr john d
martini will be on there as well uh we
have um marissa pierre one of the top
hypno therapists in the world will be on
there as well we've got lisa feldman
barrett one of the top neuroscientists
and neuropsychologists in the whole
world she will be there as well
an nlp master will be there as well and
let me see who else we have uh
um so jack marissa
lisa uh murica who else do we have andre
do i miss anybody
yeah we got john d martinez we have six
experts five six experts plus a whole
bunch of our clients who um
are using our brain training techniques
to change their brain so they change
their income and
the the thing that's really the most
important right
is if you feel like you're standing on
the edge of your potential that you know
that you can achieve more but
something's holding you back
whether it's fear fear of um failure
fear of being embarrassed ashamed
ridiculed judge that's normal
whether it's um limiting beliefs well
that's normal we all have them whether
it's
self-image where you really don't feel
you deserve the success or even if you
don't have the knowledge or skills right
these things hold us back that's the
truth
well just because we have obstacles
doesn't mean we can't overcome the
obstacles but if we don't know how
then it's harder if we know how then we
have a skill
right so then we have a skill so if you
want to learn the how
um to
you know remove your mental and
emotional obstacles join us for the
brain of thought it's october the 23rd
which is a saturday from nine o'clock
about three or four o'clock uh it's free
go to my page and dm direct message me
brain just the one word brain my system
will set you up with a link to go and
sign up for free and invite your friends
and then
how phenomenal it is
i love it one last question because i
know you're so
i've seen a lot of behind the scenes
with you and how much you care about
your community and how much you just
love on the people inside
people going to come they're going to
learn from you they can learn from all
these great experts
what are you doing on the community side
here for people to also now connect to
other people because
so many people feel like they're so
alone
and when they're in this tribe they're
going to win
yeah so there's um
there's four things that i'd like
everybody to consider right number one
we need the right mindset right
number two we need the right skill set
number three uh we need the right action
set of the behavior what should i do but
then number four is the environment that
i'm in
right and so if i could be in an
environment that i could learn i could
share i could give i can get help i can
ask questions
then
i start to feel like i can do this
and when we start to share with each
other you know what's working what's not
working then we learn with each other
one of the models in my company is this
let's lift each other up as we climb
let's lift each other up as we climb so
that means that i'm going to have a hand
up and somebody's helping me i'm gonna
have a hand down and i'm lifting
somebody up we need each other
we need each other we need each other to
to motivate each other we need each
other to learn from each other we need
each other to see what's working what's
not we need each other to to make it
easier
right and so in all of my work you know
i have communities that that people are
a part of where we we share we love we
care and we lift each other up so
instead of putting each other down
there's enough going on in the world uh
where people are putting each other down
i don't care uh what your age is what
your ethnicity is where you live in the
world i don't care uh your gender it
makes no difference we are all uh made
in the image of the creator that made us
i don't care what you call it
but the intelligence in me is the same
intelligence in you the the creative
intelligence and force that created me
created you and everything else you know
on our beautiful blue planet and in this
universe and so why not have a healthy
love and respect for each other and help
each other and if we all did that then
guess what we'd all do better
john ashdraft ladies and gentlemen if
you don't know him already you will love
him i promise go check out the
brain-a-thon his ninth annual event you
can deal with him
there it is there's the lineup dm him
the word brain on instagram or youtube
check the link in the description below
appreciate you man thank you as always
thank you appreciate you too bye
everyone
much love bye if you want to see my last
one-on-one with the amazing john astrav
check out the video right there next to
me i think you'll love it continue to
believe and i'll see you there do you
think i can heal
my broken neck with meditation when when
doctors say it's not going to connect do
you think i can manifest that connection
happening with that bone that broke up
yes